Her low freak bitches.
So dice is such a maniac.
He makes this album when he's selling
out Madison Square Garden,
he's selling out the Nassau Coliseum.
He sell him out Gi and places like,
I think to this day it's like Kevin Hart
and him.
I like the biggest as far as like the
most successful John Kevin Hart's done
like 60,000
seat places and say,
yeah,
I mean he's,
he's,
what's the new word?
Philly.
It was like 60,000
pounds of trailer for it out.
Now what's next?
It's a,
it's insane.
I mean,
he's a insane,
literally.
And I said,
I think I told you before his,
his phone bill or electric bill at one
point was in my name because he was so
like,
he asked me if I could put it,
my name's to,
we're going to turn the electricity off.
Wow.
I can fill it.
That's crazy.
Holy Shit.
Yeah,
like nuts where he's at now.
Wow,
that's crazy.
It's great.
My Mom's still has no scope of that at
all.
Shook.
You're out in la.
She goes,
tell Kev we said,
whoa.
I'm like,
I'm probably going to see him.
He's probably in Bulgaria doing a
fucking covered by body guards.
Yeah,
riding on a wave of diamonds,
wearing his own sneakers.
I had a genuine a bomb out.
Like I felt bad about it too and it was
before,
you know,
I was having a rough go.
I was headlining a the Sacramento Improv
or punchlines second to a punchline,
which I love that club and I was
headlining it and I felt pretty good
about headlining it.
I'm like,
you know,
seven show week or whatever it is,
but I'm like,
this is great.
I'm headlining the punchline.
Sacramento.
Kevin was in town doing the Arco arena
where the Sacramento Kings play and I'm
like,
all right.
He goes,
hey man,
come to the hotel and hang out.
I go,
absolutely.
And I go to the hotel where outside for
a 30 seconds when I get to the hotel,
he's coming out of like the hotel gym.
It's like around the corner and I meet
him and we're walking to the hotel on
this like a hundred foot walk.
Car Stopped.
People pour out of buildings,
people start yelling and screaming.
He turns around and gives them one way.
If we go into the hotel,
we go up to his suite.
That is amazing.
It's got a whole bunch of his boys
there.
They're playing a xbox three 60 the time
it was and he goes,
you went to watch the,
um,
he was doing or watch the intro for my
special,
my dad was not this one.
It's out now.
The one before where he's got the
pyrotechnics going off.
He's like,
yeah,
we got pyro and it's going off.
He showed me this crazy like insane
trailer for it that's just like mind
blowing.
And I was feeling so good about,
oh,
I'm sorry.
I should preface this story by saying,
um,
when I was talking to the cab driver
bringing me to calves hotel,
he was like,
what are you scrolling from a hotel to a
hotel for?
And I go off,
you want to hear the story?
It's pretty,
I said,
Kevin Hart's here and I'm a,
he's all buddy of mine sent me to go
hang out with them.
And he's like,
yeah,
go.
Yeah,
I'm in town.
I'm a comedian too.
I'm playing the punchline and went and
he goes,
oh,
that's amazing man,
cause can I get tickets?
And I was like,
yeah,
I could like put you on the list for
some tickets if you want to say like
what show you want to come to.
There's like two shows and there or
something.
He goes to shows at the argo arena.
And I was like,
oh no.
He goes,
oh I'm sorry man.
I thought I want to take it to Kevin
Hart show.
Oh they guy's like,
okay.
He asking you for Kevin Hart's tickets.
So that's how that starts.
That's how this thing starts.
And he gives me his card,
this cab driver,
he goes,
call me when you're done cause I'll be
right in the area.
Okay.
I go up.
So Kev showing me the pyrotechnics,
if it was easy,
you went lobster,
we're all getting lobsters and shit.
I'm not even exaggerating.
It's like this kind of hang and I'm
like,
this is fucking crazy.
And,
uh,
and his buddies are all playing the xbox
and I said,
try to find some like sign of like old
Kevin there,
you know what I mean?
Not,
not that he's,
he hasn't personalities,
not shitty or anything.
Just like,
you know,
connect on some level of what our
friendship is.
I'm like,
you still bring your xbox everywhere
highs.
I still do that too.
I pack it up in a like Schlep it with me
everywhere I go so I could do something
during the day.
And he goes,
oh no man,
because every time we land we send a guy
out to buy an xbox for the day and then
we leave it for the maids.
And I was like,
I gotta go and I left like in a weird
short amount of time and the guy picks
me up in the cab and we're driving back
to my hotel and he's scans me these
questions like,
how was it man?
How was it was fine.
I'm like,
I wasn't that when like a contest to
meet him.
Like I know and he's like,
Oh man,
he's so funny.
It's craig goes by the way,
cause I feel like a dick.
Um,
I'd love to,
if to offer stop.
I'd love to come to one of your shows
this weekend.
I go,
yeah man,
absolutely.
Let me know.
He's like,
my wife would love it man.
He goes,
I'll bring her out because I look really
cool.
I'll be like,
hey,
I know the comedian stuff and I'll be
like,
yeah man,
whatever you want.
So I go,
it's just stop before we got out of the
car,
just tell me what show which surely you
want to go to.
And we pull up to the hotel like,
you know,
it's kind of a quiet 15 minutes ride and
I'm getting ready to go.
So hey buddy,
what's your name?
So I'll put you in for tickets.
He goes,
honestly man,
I'm not going to come.
Why do you keep building me up to hurt
my feelings?
What the fuck man,
I'm going out of his way.
Yeah,
that was like the saddest.
I was headlining the punchline.
I was excited.
I was,
and then all of a sudden I was like,
Jesus,
man,
I I the call,
like I've made phone calls back home
like why am I so like just fucking
awfully green with envy.
I just showed it all over my ass in that
room.
It's tough.
Well,
first of all,
that cab driver wasn't helping anything
that kind of put you in a weird state of
mind.
He was an idiot.
So you went,
you went to Kevin's place,
you were driven her out by an idiot and
you're going to see the most successful
comedian of all time.
Yeah.
Who is your friend who you helped with?
His electrical bill and you get in there
and they're throwing away xbox just to
meet lobsters.
I got assume you're a high as fuck,
right?
Will you hide when you went over there?
I maybe had to be there.
Those guys aren't really doing anything
like that.
But you probably did before you went
over there for sure.
Right?
I know I would.
Yeah.
That scared the fuck out of me.
I'd be like,
ah,
it's too rich.
I got to get away from him.
Sorry.
I said a meltdown,
I'm like,
hey,
they go,
well,
you know,
[inaudible] I don't understand how a guy
like that can work as much as he does.
Um,
being meaning,
I don't know.
Not that I don't understand that he's at
ambitious.
I don't understand where the time comes
from.
I mean,
it's several movies I think still coming
out.
Well,
it's a,
it's also stand up and it's also,
I mean,
he's just on top of it.
Social media is,
social media is like a business to him.
Yeah.
It's a really interesting guy,
man.
Like super,
super ambitious.
Well,
the new,
uh,
the new trailer for the,
for the new special says he goes,
uh,
comedy's first ever.
Mogul and gas sort of.
I guess so.
I mean,
for sure.
Well,
whatever,
who gives a fuck about first ever this
or that he's about to say,
but as a mom,
what other comedian was a mogul you
think was a real,
like Jerry Seinfeld running a business?
The branch.
I mean,
Kevin's got sneakers.
Does he?
He's cool.
I didn't know Scott.
Nike sneakers.
Yeah.
Okay.